THE AUGUST THIRTIETH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS SAYS BANDS
HEARING IN. TODAY WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE BILLS
ON THE SUSPENSE FILE NO ONE I
THINK MY VICE CHAIR MISTER
BIGELOW FOR HIS AND FEELING
COOPERATION IN HELPING MOVE
THESE FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER
BIGELOW. I ALSO WANT TO HAND IT
TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THESE BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE. AND I'D LOVE FOR THE
REST OF MY COLLEAGUES TO JOIN
US SO WE CAN ENSURE THAT. WE
HAVE THEM ON THE ROLL CALL. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
APPROPRIATIONS STAFF AND
REPUBLICAN FISCAL STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK THROUGHOUT THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU. OUR LAST
COUPLE MONTHS WE'VE MOVED TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE BILLS
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. AND NOW
IT IS TIME FOR US TO DISPENSE
WITH THEM. I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THE BILL PACKETS ARE
ORGANIZED BY AUTHOR IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER. THEIR
ONLINE AT THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES
WEBSITE WHICH IS LOCATED AT
EIGHT P. R. O. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT G. O. V. NOW THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT SO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE MY COLLEAGUES
UNDERSTAND. THE REASON WE'RE
DOING THIS IS WE WATCH FOR A
COUPLE YEARS THE SENATE
DISPENSED OF THEIR BILLS AND
THAT FORM. AND WE THOUGHT IT
WAS A GOOD WAY TO ORGANIZE THE
MATERIAL RATHER THAN TO DO IT
BY SUBJECT. SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY IT TODAY IF
YOU GUYS LIKE IT WILL KEEP IT
THAT WAY IF PEOPLE REALLY DON'T
WE WILL NOT. YOU WILL GET. THE
BILLS IN FRONT OF YOU BY LAST
NAME AND YOU CAN MAKE NOTES ON
THE FORMS I THINK THAT THEY
COME IN PACKETS. OR LIKE LATER
THIS AFTERNOON YES FOLLOWING
TODAY'S HEARING THE COMMITTEE
WILL POST THE UNOFFICIAL
RESULTS OF THE SUSPENSE FILE
HEARING ON THE SAME WEBSITE. IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
ADD MISTER BIGELOW. YES FIRST I
WANT TO COMPLIMENT YOU ON YOUR
EFFORTS TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES IN AN EFFECTIVE.
EFFICIENT MANNER I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF ON FOR BOTH. OF
US WE HAVE HAD A GOOD TIME
WORKING THIS YEAR AND WE
FOCUSED IN ON TRYING TO
STREAMLINE TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER FOR ALL. I HOPE FOR THE
MEMBERS THIS IS EFFECTIVE FOR
YOU AND USEFUL IN THIS CHANGE
TODAY IF YOU WILL SOME OF US
WILL HAVE A PACKET AND WORKING
WITH IT SOME OF US WILL BE.
WORKING ELECTRONICALLY. PLEASE
GIVE US THE FEEDBACK SO THAT WE
COULD NOT MAKE IT BETTER OR-
MAKE THE CHANGES THAT NEED TO
BE MADE. SO AGAIN THANK YOU AS
A GROUP. AND IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK AND SERVE WITH
YOU. ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE CAN
BEGIN WE NEED MR GABRIEL OUR
MYSTERY BOSS ONE OR TWO OF THEM
TO MAKE IT DOWN. TO THE HEARING
IN THE MEANTIME WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND CALL ROLE IN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY. GONZALEZ BIGELOW
BLOOM. BONTA BROUGH CALDERON
CARRILLO CHAU DEEP EGGMAN FONG
GABRIEL GARCIA. MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE. PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
HERE RIVAS. GREAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE WE CAN START. I'M GONNA DO
IT TAKE ONE BILL OUT OF ORDER
BECAUSE I REALIZE THERE ARE
NUMBER PEOPLE WHO TRAVELED SOME
LONG DISTANCE TO HEAR THIS BILL
AND I THINK THERE WAS
MISCOMMUNICATION AND HOW
QUICKLY THESE GO ALONG
SOMETIMES QUICKER THAN OTHERS
AND SO RATHER THAN MAKE YOU
WAIT THRILLED AT TWO HUNDRED
BILLS BEFORE CARRYING YOUR BILL
WILL GO AHEAD AND DISPENSE OF
THAT FIRST. OUR FIRST BILL THEN
WILL BE AT SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
BY SENATOR PAN. A BILL
REGARDING IMMUNIZATIONS THE
MOTION COMES FROM DOCTOR QUIRK.
THE SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
IF IT'S WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
SUBSTITUTE THAT MOTION AND
SECOND FOR ALL DO PASS OR DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE
REST OF THE SUSPENSE FILE. WITH
THAT WILL MOVE ON TO AUTHOR. I
EAT YOU GUYS ARE WELCOME TO
STAY FOR THE MEETING I WOULD
ASK THE PEOPLE COME OFF THE
CHAIRS OF THE LIABILITY AND A
LITTLE DANGEROUS BUT OTHERWISE
WE WILL RESUME THE MEETING I
DON'T MIND IF YOU STAND I DON'T
MIND IF YOU SIT THERE BUT- WE
CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE STANDING ON
CHAIRS
. I'M GONNA ASK ONCE
AGAIN THAT THE PEOPLE STANDING
ON CHAIRS STEP DOWN THAT IS A
LIABILITY WE WOULDN'T WANT
ANYONE GET HURT HERE. SO WE
CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE JUST STANDING
ON CHAIRS ALL DURING THE
MEETING. IF NOT I'M GONNA HAVE
TO ASK THE SERGEANTS TO ASK YOU
TO SIT DOWN OR LEAVE. ALL RIGHT
I'M GOING TO TEMPORARILY
ADJOURNED THE APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING UNTIL WE CAN GET PEOPLE.
I'M SORRY NOT ADJOURN RECESS
THE THANK YOU ALL HE SAID THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THAT
WOULD BE DEVASTATING FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE. MR P. AND WOULD BE
HAPPY THE REST OF US COULD
SUFFER I MEAN IT'S VERY RECESS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND TELL WE- HAVE PEOPLE WHO
CAN SIT DOWN THANK YOU
. IF WE
CAN HAVE THE REST OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RETURN TO THE HEARING
ROOM. WE WILL WAIT
. ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND.
KEEP GOING I A I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT WE DO NOT LIKE
PEOPLE PUTTING THEMSELVES IN
DANGER AND THOSE CHAIR ARE
EXTREMELY OLDS. AND MAYBE ARE
NOT FORTIFIED IN SO IT PROBABLY
IS NOT THE SAFEST THING TO
STAND ON BUT IF THAT'S WHAT YOU
CHOOSE TO DO AS LONG AS A YOU
DO NOT DESTRUCT AS WE'RE GOING
TO CARRY ON IN THIS. MEETING WE
HAD A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
WE WERE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE FOR.
ALL ADDITIONAL. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. I
UNDERSTAND YOU WANT TO GET
ARRESTED. YOU'VE BEEN CLEAR.
YOU CAN READ. YOU CAN YOU CAN
PEOPLE HERE. YEAH WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE THEN. ARE WE
READY. WE. WE HAVE A MOTION. HI
DOCTOR QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO. WE ARE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THAT MOTION FOR ALL
FUTURE BILLS. SB THREE BY
MISTER ALLEN HIGHER EDUCATION
COORDINATING BODY THAT'S A TO
YOUR BILL. SB FIFTY FOUR. ALLEN
CALIFORNIA PLASTIC POLLUTION
REDUCTION DO YOU PASSED ON A B.
ROLL CALL. SB FIFTY NINE ALLEN
A THàNH A MIS VEHICLE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB
ONE THIRTY NINE ALLEN COUNTY
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. TO PASS WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ONE
CHANGE THAT COUNTY THRESHOLD
FROM TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS. OR MORE TO FOR
HENDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS OR
MORE. REMOVE THE CONTINGENCY ON
AN APPROPRIATION FOR SMALL
COUNTIES THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. SB TWO NINETY SIX BY
MISTER ALLEN STUDENT FINANCIAL
AID FOR ASYLUM SEEKERS. DO YOU
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
THREE NINETY TWO MISTER ALLEN
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY DO PASSED
WITH A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATUTE
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
MOVING ON TO MISTER ARCHULETA.
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE ARCHULETA
MEDI CAL WAIVER SERVICES FOR
MILITARY FAMILIES DO PASSED ON
A ROLL CALL. SB THREE NINETY
FIVE ARCHULETA ROADSIDE
WILDLIFE'S SALVAGE PERMITS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT ARCHULETA
DISOBEYED DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM DO
PASSED ON A ROLL CALL. SB ONE
ATKINS CALIFORNIA FIRE MENTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORKERS
DEFENSE. DO YOU PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS. REVISED IN
RE CAST THE LISTING AND TAKING
PROVISIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT AS IT
RELATES TO ACTIONS TAKEN BY
FISHING GAME COMMISSION AND
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
BY DFW AND THE COMMISSION WITH
SOME FLEXIBILITY WITH FEDERAL
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS AND TAKE
STATEMENTS. OR PERMITS IF THE
FEDERAL PROTECTIONS AS OF
JANUARY SEVENTEENTH TWENTY
SEVEN TEEN DO NOT SATISFY STATE
REQUIREMENTS. EXPRESS
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO PROVIDE
DFW. WITH SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
FOR CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
THE FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS AND REDUCE IN REVISED
THE AIRBOARD REPORTING
REQUIREMENT ON FEDERAL BASELINE
CHANGES. FIVE ALLOW THE AIR
BOARD TO USE NON REGULATORY
OPTIONS TO ME BASS LINE FEDERAL
STANDARDS. SIX REVISED AND
RECAST PROVISIONS RELATING TO
WATER QUALITY AND DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS. SEVEN PROVIDE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION FOR AIR
AND WATER STANDARDS IF THE
FEDERAL STATUTE ALLOWING THEM
IS REVOKED AND EIGHT REVISED
PROVISIONS RELATING TO THAT
OPTION OF THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES. THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL
. WE'RE GONNA GET
INTERPRETATION IF WE NEED TO
INSURE THAT WE CAN BE HEARD. ON
THE VIDEO. FEED THAT WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY HAVE BECAUSE OF
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT SO
WE'RE GOING TO GET A. A
DECISION WHETHER WE HAVE TO.
STOP WHILE IS STOP THE CHANT
TEAM OR IF WE CAN MOVE ON
. HEY
WE JUST GOT CLARIFICATION THAT
IN FACT I CAN BE HEARD SO WE
WILL CONTINUE. WITH SB SIXTY
SIX ATKINS CLINIC BILLING FOR
TO MEDI CAL IT VISITS ON THE
SAME DAY. DO YOU PASS ON IN A
ROLL CALL. SB FOUR FIFTY ONE
ATKINS HISTORIC BUILDING TAX
CREDIT DO YOU PASSED WITH
TECHNO NECK TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ON A ROLL CALL. SB
FOUR SIXTY FIVE BATES EMERGENCY
PLANNING FUNDING THAT'S A TO
YOUR BILL. SB FIVE FORTY ONE
BATES SCHOOL BASED ACTIVE
SHOOTER IN LOCKDOWN DRILLS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO SIMPLY REPORT
ABOUT SCHOOL GYRLS AND IDENTIFY
BEST PRACTICES THAT'S GET OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. SB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE BATES MARKETING OF
SUBSTANCE USE SERVICES. DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO STRIKE A
PROVISION APPLYING CURRENT
PROHIBITIONS ON PATIENT
BROKERING TO THIRD PARTY
ADVERTISERS IN RECOVERY
RESIDENCES THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SB SEVEN FORTY SIX
BATES HEALTH CARE COVERAGE OF
ANTI CANCER MEDICAL DEVICES
HOLD IN COMMITTEE. SB FIVE BELL
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DO PASS
. ALL
RIGHT JUST TO CLARIFY SB FIVE
BUT BY MISTER BELL GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL SB SIX BY MISTER
BELL SURPLUS LAND DATABASE DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB TEN
BALANCE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HERE
SERVICE SIR PEER SUPPORT
SERVICES. TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL
. SB TWELVE BELL MENTAL
HEALTH DROP IN CENTERS FOR YOU
HOLDEN COMMITTING. SB ONE
FIFTEEN BELL HIGHER EDUCATION
GRANTS FOR FOSTER YEARS DO YOU
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE
AUTHORITY TO DO DR GRANT MONEY
FROM FUTURE YEARS. THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB ONE
NINETY SIX BELT COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS DO YOU PASSED WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB TWO ONE ONE BELL STATE
HIGHWAYS LEASES TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
BELL CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REQUIRE CTC TO REVIEW
ACCOMPANYING DOCUMENTATION FOR
NOMINATED PROJECT TO ENSURE IT
MEETS REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB TWO
EIGHTY TWO BELL HOUSING FOR
PAROLEES THAT'S A TO YOUR BILL.
SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO BELL.
FUNDING SET ASIDE FOR USE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB SIX OH
THREE MORE JESS SMALL
INDEPENDENT TELEPHONE
CORPORATION RATES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB TWO EIGHTEEN BY
MISTER BRADFORD. LOCAL F. E. H.
A. ENFORCEMENT DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LIMIT THE PROGRAM TO
LOS ANGELES THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL SB TWO FIFTY FIVE
BRADFORD. THIS ENTERPRISE
PROCUREMENT DO YOU PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO REVISE
REPORTING REVENUE THRESHOLD
REQUIRED CLASSES OF UTILITIES
TO SUBMIT PROCUREMENT DATA IN
RE REMOVE REQUIREMENT THE C. S.
L. B. AS SAYS THE CPUC. PACKETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB TWO
SIXTY NINE BRADFORD WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO STRIDES SECTION FOR FROM THE
BILL THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AND SPEECH FOR TWENTY SIX
BRADFORD CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSALLY UNIVERSITY TIMELY
FELLOWS PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB FOUR FIFTY FIVE
BRADFORD FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT
FUND TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB
FOUR NINETY SEVEN BRADFORD
ENERGY COMMISSION ANNUAL REPORT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SB FIVE
NINETEEN BRADFORD U. S. T.
CLEAN UP FIND ELIGIBILITY TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE BRADFORD STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB FIVE NINETY FIVE
BRADFORD FEE WAIVERS AND
DEFERRALS ARE CANNABIS LICENSES
TO PASS ON AMENDED TO SPECIFY
AS A NEEDS BASED ALLOCATION FOR
FEE WAIVERS. THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL. SB SEVEN OH FOUR
BRADFORD UNIVERSAL TELEPHONE
SERVICES ACT DO PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS REQUIRE ONLY
CONSIDERATION OF WAYS TO
IMPROVE ENROLLMENT BY
CALIBRATION MEDIC CALPERS HIS
OFFENSE. REQUIRE CONSIDERATION
OF AN AUTOMATIC ENROLLMENT OF
L. I. H. E. A. P. AND CARE
CUSTOMERS AND LIFELINE. THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. SB TWO THIRTY COPY AT A
LAW ENFORCEMENT USE OF DEADLY
FORCE TRAINING DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL SB TWO NINETY A COPY AT
ALL POVERTY REPORT HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SB THREE SEVENTEEN
COPY AT ALL PROHIBITED
CHEMICALS IN SEPTIC SYSTEMS. TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE
STATE WATER BOARD OR REGIONAL
BOARDS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
THROUGH WASTE DISCHARGE FROM
ANSWER WAIVERS. THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. SB FOUR
FOURTEEN HAVE A NO SMALL WATER
SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION THAT'S A
TO YOUR BILL. SB FOUR SEVENTY
TWO COMING AT ALL WAGE BASED
AND WORK BASED ADVANCES DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF ALLOWABLE FAILED PAYMENTS
BACK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
SB FORTY SEVEN COPY AT ALL D.
W. R. ARIEL SNOW SURVEYED TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB FIVE
FIFTEEN HAVE A AT ALL HIGH
HAZARD ZONE FUEL REPORT THAT'S
A TO YOUR BILL. SB FIVE EIGHTY
ONE COPY AT ALL PUBLIC DATA
DISCLOSURE ON CANNABIS LICENSES
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO NARROW
THEIR INFORMATION REQUIRED DATA
ALLOW AGENCIES DISCRETION TO
SEND THE INFORMATION IN A
SPECIFIED FOR MAN'S DATA
POSTING. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL SB SIX ELEVEN COMING
AT ALL MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
HOUSING TASK FORCE TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
COMING AT ALL PRINT OUT BY
PASSED TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB SIX NINETY SEVEN CABALLERO
RULES FOR SUPERVISION OF
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS DO PASS AS
AMENDED. TO REMOVE PROVISIONS
AUTHORIZING ORGANIZE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM OR ITS ADMINISTRATORS
HAVE DEVELOPED. PRACTICE
AGREEMENTS CLARIFY CHANGES TO
THE SUPERVISION DEFINITION DO
NOT THAT DO NOT PROHIBIT THE
BOARD FROM IMPOSING DISCIPLINE.
AND SPECIFY THAT THE PRACTICE
AGREEMENT SHALL ESTABLISH
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
IDENTIFY AS SUPERVISING.
PHYSICIAN THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. MOVING ON DOMESTIC
CHANGE. SB THIRTY FIVE BY MISS
CHANGE HUMAN TRAFFICKING TASK
FORCE TO PASS AS AMENDED
REQUIRED TO DO JADE PROVIDE
STAFF AND RESOURCES TO EXTEND
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE. THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB TWO
THIRTY NINE CHAIN CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE LIMITATIONS OF
ACTIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SB
NINETEEN MOVING ON TO MISTER
DODD. STREAM GAGES DO PASS. A
ROLL CALL SB ONE THIRTY SEVEN
DOT TRANSPORTATION FUNDS
EXCHANGE PROGRAM DO PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE PROJECTS
MEET FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS LIMIT
CHANGES TO A HUNDRED MILLION IN
FISCAL YEAR AND REQUIRE
CALTRANS TO CONSULT WITH A
LEGAL CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SEE
SAD THAT GETS OUT ON ANY ROLL
CALL SB ONE NINETY DOT FIRE
SAFETY BUILDING STANDARDS
DEFENSIBLE SPACE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LIMIT CERTAIN CAL
FIRE REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. SB TWO OH NINE
DODD CAL FIGHT WHILE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE WARNING CENTER DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO RESTRUCTURE
WILDFIRE CENTER THAT GETS OUT
IN A ROLL CALL SB TWO FORTY
SEVEN DOT WILDFIRE PREVENTION
TO PASS WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO MOVE AUDIT REASON
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE WILD FIRE
SAFETY DIVISION THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL SB TWO FIFTY
THREE DOT ENVIRONMENTAL FARM
INCENTIVES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
SB TWO NINETY DIED RE RE
INSURANCE FOR NATURAL DISASTER
pTHREE FIFTY TWO DOT ADDITIONAL
ALCOHOL LICENSES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SB FOUR FORTY TWO
DODD STATE PARKS
COMMERCIALIZATION PERMITS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REVISE
PROVISIONS RELATING TO
PERMISSIONS. AND BENEFIT
SHARING AGREEMENT SECONDS OUT
IN IN A ROLL CALL. MOVING ON TO
MY FAVORITE MISTER GRASSO SB
TWENTY NINE TO RISE SO MEDI CAL
DISABILITY FOR UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS
RELATED OUT REACH PLANNING
REPORTING INCOME CONTINUITY OF
PROVIDERS AND TO CONFORM TO
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB THREE
FIFTY FOUR DID I SO LOANS FOR
GRADUATE STUDENT DREAMERS DO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
THREE SIXTY FIVE DROUGHT SO CAL
WORKS IMMEDIATE NEEDS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO NARROW THE CHILD
CARE PROVISIONS. DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION MAKE CLEAR FINE
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE DID
ALSO VICTIM COMPENSATION DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB SIX
TWENTY TWO THAT I SO CIVIL
DETENTION FACILITY STATE
INVESTIGATION TO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL. SB SEVEN FORTY NINE
THE RUSSELL CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT TRADE SECRETS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PRESERVE THE
CONFIDENTIALITY.
CONFIDENTIALITY AND TAX
INFORMATION IN EXEMPTS CAL
COMPETES TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. MOVING ON TO MISS
GALGIANI. SB SIXTY EIGHT
GALGIANI TREATED WOOD WASTE DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO ADDED
TO YOUR SUNSET THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. SB TWO SIXTEEN
GALGIANI USE HEAVY DUTY TRUCK
EXCHANGE HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SB
FOUR FIFTY NINE GALGIANI RATE
IN GREAT BODILY INJURY DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. SB FIVE THIRTY
GALGIANI SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING
CONSTRUCTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CLARIFY TIME INSTANCE GO BY
TRAINING. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL. SB SEVEN OH SIX GALGIANI
PULMONARY HYPERTENSION TASK. DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SPECIFY A
SENSE I SENSE THAT DATE BACK
IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB
SEVEN SIXTY THREE GALGIANI
GROSS INCOME EXCLUSION FOR
FORGIVEN MORTGAGE DEBT HOLDING.
COMMITTEE SB EIGHT GLAZIER
SMOKING BAN. WHICH IS GOING TO
CALL. FOURTEEN GLAZER HIGHER
EDUCATION FACILITIES BOND TO
PASS TO THE RULES COMMITTEE. ON
A ROLL CALL NO. GET ON A ROLL
CALL SB ONE FORTY EIGHT GLAZER
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROMISE PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
GLAZER RENTERS TAX CREDIT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR GLACIER WINE TASTING ROOM
LICENSES HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
SIX OH SIX GLAZER CEMETERY AND
FUNERAL BUREAU AND BORDER
BARBERING IN COSMETOLOGY SENSE
EXTENSIONS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SIX AWAY GLAZER
CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS BOARD IN
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS TECHNICAL
COMMITTEE SUNSET EXTENSIONS DO
PASSED ON A ROLL CALL. SB SIX
OH NINE GLACIER. AN
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES SUNSET
EXTENSION TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. I'LL CALL SB SIX FIFTY
ONE GLACIER DISCOVERY POST
CONVICTION TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
GLAZER EACH BE TEST LOOKS
MANSION AREA TO YOUR BILL AB
ONE SIXTY THREE GRAY ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES I'M SORRY DID I GET
THAT WRONG AB ONE. SIX WE WERE.
YOU HAVE A TWO YEAR I'M SORRY
I'M DOING GREAT I HAVE MR
GRAY'S IS IN HERE IT'S DOESN'T
FOLLOW ALL OF YOURS AB. SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE. MR GRAY ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB SIX EIGHTY THREE GROVE
REGIONAL CENTERS DATA
TRANSPARENCY HOLDING COMMITTEE
SB FIFTY ONE HERTZBERG CANNABIS
BANKING TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
SB SIXTY THREE HERTZBERG TAXES
AND STUDENT LOANS DO PASSED
WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB TWO OH FIVE
HERTZBERG STORM WATER DISCHARGE
COMPLIANCE TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB TWO THIRTY SEVEN
HERTZBERG STAM LAUREATE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB TWO FIFTY EIGHT
HERTZBERG PETS IN HOMELESS
SHELTERS HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
SIX FIFTY EIGHT I'M SORRY SB
TWO SIXTY FIVE HERTZBERG SCHOOL
MEAL SERVICES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE SUNSET
DATE AND TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
SB THREE FORTY TWO HERTZBERG
MISLEADING ADVERTISING DOMAIN
AND SUB DOMAIN NAMES IT'S A TO
YOUR BILL. SB FIVE TWENTY
HERTZBERG ELECTRICAL SERVICE
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT DO YOU
PASSED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE CPUC RETAINS
AUTHORITY TO DESIGNATE. AOL ARE
IN TO RELIEVE A RB OF NEED TO
CONSULT WITH C. P. YOU SEE THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB ONE
NINETY NINE HILL OFFICES SAFETY
ADVOCATE TO PASS ON ANY ROLL
CALL SB TWO NINETY FOUR HILL
WELFARE EXEMPTION DO PASS I'M
SORRY WELFARE EXEMPTION CAP TO
PASS ON ANY WHAT. ROLL CALL SB
FOUR TWENTY FIVE HILL SEXUAL
ABUSE AND MISCONDUCT REPORTING
FOR HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN HILL TRANSPARENCY
ON WORKERS COMPENSATION COSTS
AND SERVICES TO PASS AS AMENDED
REQUIRE MEDICAL NETWORKS TO
DISCLOSE REIMBURSEMENT 20% OR
MORE BELOW THE OFFICIAL MEDICAL
FEE SCHEDULE. ON A STANDARDIZED
FORM IN THE PAYER SIGNS AND NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT WAS
SPECIFIED EXEMPTION SECONDS OUT
IN AN ARRAY ROLL CALL. SB SIX
SEVENTY TWO HEALTH CITY OF
BRISBANE HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
THREE THIRTEEN WEST THOSE
CIRCUITS ANIMAL PROHIBITIONS DO
COOPER PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL.
SB THREE SIXTY SEVEN ONE SO
COASTAL CONSERVANCY GRANTS
IMPROPER PROGRAMS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB FOUR SIXTEEN WEST
OAKS MANY WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIONS FOR PEACE OFFICER
RESEARCHERS. DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB FOUR
TWENTY TWO WEST HIRING. CREDIT
FOR EX OFFENDERS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
WEST SO COMMISSION ON
CALIFORNIA MEXICO FAIRS TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. SB SIX SIXTY
SEVEN WEST SO ORGANICS
RECYCLING THAT'S A TO YOUR
BILL. SB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
WEST SO INITIATIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ABROAD HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB TWO SIXTY MISTER
TODD THOUGH STREAMLINED
ENROLLMENT AND HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS DO PASSED IN A ROLL
CALL. SB THREE THIRTY ONE OR
TWO OTHER COUNTY BASED SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLANS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB THREE FIFTY ONE
OR TWO OTHER CLIMATE CHANGE TCC
PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
SB FOUR FIFTY THREE TADO BEST
PRACTICES REPORT FOR THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING DO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTSSB FOUR NINE YEAR TO
OTHER CALPERS BENEFITS I AM A
ROLL CALL I'M SORRY ON FOR
FIFTY THREE. SB FOUR NINETY
TADO CALPERS BENEFITS OVER
ISSUANCE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
OVER ISSUANCE OF QUESTIONS
BASED ON AGE AND SS I BENEFITS
REQUIRED DSS TO DEVELOP A
POLICY REGARDING A MINISTRY
BEAR CLAIMS FOR CERTAIN
HOUSEHOLDS DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
TO ONGOING AUTOMATION IS
COMPLETE THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SB FIVE THIRTEEN
TADO PRIVATE WATER WELL GRANTS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB FIVE
FIFTY NINE OR TALLER. FRAME
CURRENT CANAL FUNDING TO YOUR
BILL. SB ONE SIXTY JACKSON
MAYBE NOT A MISS JACKSON AT THE
MARGINS HE PLANNING A CULTURAL
COMPETENCE TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CLARIFY COMMUNITY OUTREACH
REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS OUT IN
ANY ROLL CALL. SB ONE SEVENTY
ONE JACKSON PAY DATA REPORTING
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB ONE
SEVENTY SIX JACKSON STATE PARK
CALIFORNIA. DO PASS AS AMENDED
CHANGE ALLOCATION OF FUNDS
GENERATED BY THE STATE BAR
LOYALTY PROGRAMS. THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO JACKS AND LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT HIGH RISK HIGH RISK
FIRE AREAS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REMOVE THE GDR IF I NEED
PROVISIONS. AND INSTEAD MAKE
THE GRANT PROGRAM CONTINGENT
UPON APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. LIMIT THE GRANT
PROGRAM TO SMALL JURISDICTION
TO MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB TWO
TWENTY EIGHT JACKSON MASTER
PLAN ON AGING DO YOU PLAY PASS
AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE
SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
LEAD THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MASTER
PLAN. SPECIFY THE CORE VALUES
TO BY THE MASTER PLAN REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO
REPORT BY OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY AND TO PROVIDE PERIODIC
UPDATES. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SB TWO EIGHTY
JACKSON FALL PREVENTION AGING
IN PLACE TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB THREE FORTY SIX AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM RECOGNITION
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB FOUR
SIXTY EIGHT JACKSON CALIFORNIA
TAX EXPENDITURE REVIEW BOARD.
TO PASS AMENDED REVISED SCOPE
OF YOU SEE RESEARCH AND MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL IN
IMPLEMENTATION CHANGES THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
FOUR NINETY THREE JACKSON
CAMPUS SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT
THE TO YOUR BILL. SB FIVE FIFTY
ONE JACKSON PLUGGING ABANDONED
OR IDLED WILL WELLS. PASSED AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT OF DODGER DE IS
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS AT
FULL COST OF SITE REMEDIATION
TO THAT'S MAKE COSTS
REQUIREMENTS AND PROVIDE DAGGER
WITH COMPLIANCE FLEXIBILITY.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
JACKSON HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
FOR CLINICAL TRIALS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. SB FOUR FIFTY TWO
JONES CALIFORNIA CANCER
REGISTRY. BROCHURES HOLDING
COMMITTEE SB SIX SIXTY THREE
JONES. PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTIONS
AND VETERAN HALLS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. MAYBE NOT TO MISS
LEYVA SB TWENTY TWO LEYVA RAPE
KIDS TESTING TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB TWENTY FOUR LEYVA
MEDICATION ABORTION A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES TO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB TWO TEN LEYVA
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE INSPECTION
PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
CAP AIR BE FEES AT THIRTY
DOLLARS IT'S GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. SB TWO SIXTY SIX
LEYVA CALPERS AND DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION TO PASS AS
MEDICARE BY PROCESS FOR SCHOOLS
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB
THREE OH ONE LEYVA MEDI CAL
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR LEYVA COSMETIC
INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB SIX NINETY EIGHT
LEYVA YOU SEE AN LATE WAGE
PENALTIES. DO PASS. ON ANY ROLL
CALL. SB TWO SIXTY TWO MCGUIRE.
MARINE RESOURCES TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE OBSOLETE
PROVISIONS INCREASE THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE DUNGEON AS
CRAP IN SALMON FISHERIES THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB TWO
NINETY FIVE MCGUIRE TAX CREDIT
FOR HOME HARDENING COSTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB THREE
FORTY FIVE FOUR MCGUIRE LOCAL
PREPAID MTS DO PASSED WITH
CLEAR FINE AMENDMENTS TECH IS
HOW THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
SB FOR FORTY NINE MCGUIRE
PIERCE'S DISEASE TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB SIX SEVENTY
MCGUIRE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ADAGE NOTIFICATION DO PASSED
WITH AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO.
CLARIFY LANGUAGE ABOUT CREAM
THRESHOLDS FOR NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT ADDED URGENCY
CLAUSE IN THERE FOR MOVE THE
NOTICE DEADLINE FOR CAL YES TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ADD
TO THOSE CALLIE YES WILL NOTIFY
AND CLARIFY CONTENT INFORMATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SB SEVEN NINETY ONE
MCGUIRE CERTIFIED AIRCRAFT
PROPERTY TAXES TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB THREE TWENTY NINE
MAYBE NOT TO MISS MITCHELL
DISCRIMINATION HOUSING SOURCE
OF INCOME TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL. SB FOUR SIXTY FOUR
MITCHELL CALIFORNIA DIGNITY IN
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH ACT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MODIFY
REQUIREMENT DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING AND TO MAKE MINOR
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE MITCHELL JAILS
IN JUVENILE FACILITY CONTRACTS
THAT BECOMES A TO YOUR BILL. SB
SIX FORTY SEVEN MITCHELL METAL
JEWELRY STANDARDS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMONS TO CRACK TECHNICAL
ERRORS AND CHANGE THE AGE OF
CHILD TO UNDER FIFTEEN YEARS OF
AGE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SEVEN SIXTEEN MITCHELL
ONLINE OLLEGES FOR
INCARCERATED JUVENILES DO PASS
AS AMENDED ALLOWED COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT TO USE ITS
OFFICE OF EDUCATION OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FACILITIES AND
MATERIAL AND THAT MAJOR
JUVENILE FACILITIES TO USE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. MOVING ON
TO MISTER MONEY AS YOU ONE
EIGHTY NINE. WE USE AT THE WORD
EXTENSION HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB
FOUR OH SEVEN MONEY IN MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENTAL COVERAGE TO PASS
ON TO BE ROLL CALL. SB FIVE OH
FOR MONEY IN STATE ROUTE ONE TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB ONE
EIGHTY FOUR MORE LOT DEFERRED
RETIREMENT FOR JUDGES DO PASSED
WITH TECHNICAL MEMONS RELATED
TO SURVIVING SPOUSES THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE MORE LOT GHG
EMISSIONS FROM WILDFIRES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB FIVE
HUNDRED MORALE VETERANS
EDUCATION HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
ONE SEVENTY NINE NIELSEN
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES AN
ARBITRATION TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB ONE NINETY THREE NOW
SET NIELSEN NITROUS OXIDE
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. YEAH. I'M
JUST TAKING DURING. SB TWO TWO
SIX NIELSEN WATERSHED GRANT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN NIELSEN
FIREARMS PROTECTED PROHIBITED
PERSONS HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN NIELSEN STATE
MANDATE TESTS CLAIMS HOLDEN
COMMITTING. SB THREE EIGHTY TWO
NIELSEN MEDI CAL HOSPITAL
BILLION DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY DO PASS AS AMENDED
CORRECT A DRAFTING ERROR AND TO
MAKE CONTINGENT ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION.
PACKETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB
ONE FIFTY FOUR MOVING ON TO
MISTER PAN. MEDI CAL COVERAGE
FOR SILVER DIE IN MINE FLUORIDE.
I PROBABLY DIDN'T PRONOUNCE
THAT RIGHT CAN'T CAN'T HEAR
MYSELF. TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
WE WANT TO THAT ONE AGAIN SB
THREE SIXTY THREE PAN WORKPLACE
SAFETY IN STATE HOSPITALS DO
PASS AND IN A ROLL CALL. SB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT PAN SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRAINING TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB FIVE A
THREE PAN OVERSIGHT OF MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE SUBCONTRACTORS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELETE
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS. A CONFLICT.
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION CLARIFY
PLANS MAY COLLABORATE OR SHARE
MEDI CAL AUDIT FINDINGS AND
OTHER TECHNICAL CLEAR FINE
AMENDMENTS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SB SIX SIXTY PAN
COUNSELORS AT PUBLIC COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES THAT BECOMES A
TO YOUR BILL PLEASE HOLD FOR A
SECOND SO I CAN TAKE A DRINK
.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A QUICK RECESS
BUT NOT LEAVING RECESS. JUST
MAKE RECESSED
. YEAH
. YEAH. SLOW
DOWN
. YEAH
. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA START BACK UP OF
THE MEMBERS COULD COME BACK UP
.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO HEAD
RESUME SB SEVEN PORTANTINO
STATE ROUTE SEVEN TEN DO PASSED
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
DIRECT CALTRANS TO IMPLEMENT
THE PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE. GIVE
PRIORITY TO A TENANT OF NON
RESIDENTIAL SURPLUS PROPERTY
DID PURCHASE AT THE LAST. VALUE
OF FAIR MARKET VALUE OR VALUE
IN YOU IS THE PROPERTY OF THE
TEN AND IS A CITY OR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION MAKE OTHER CHANGES
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
SB SIXTY ONE PORTANTINO
FIREARMS TRANSFERRED TO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH AUTHOR MEMBERS
REQUIRE ONLY CENTER FIRE SEMI
AUTOMATIC RIFLE MAY BE SOLD HER
BAND AND BANS THE SALE OF A
SAID. SEMI AUTOMATIC CENTERFIRE
RIFLE TO ANYONE UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE THAT COULD HAPPEN
TO BE ROLL CALL. SB ONE SIXTY
THREE PORTANTINO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE FOR AUTISM SERVICES TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE
RIGHT OF PARENTS WERE CARE
GIVER TO PARTICIPATE IN
THERAPY. THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB ONE SEVENTY TWO
PORTANTINO FIREARMS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
REGULATORY ENFORCEMENT CONCERNS
IN CHAPTER IN AMENDMENTS LIKE
IT'S OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. SB
THREE OH TWO PORTANTINO
REPUBLIC OF ARMENIA TRADE
OFFICE TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB THIRTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT
PORTANTINO SCHOOL START TIME TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL. SB
THREE FORTY NINE PORTANTINO
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL SB THREE SEVENTY
SIX PORTANTINO FIREARMS TO PASS
ON TO BE ROLL CALL. SB FOR
FORTY FIVE PORTANTINO YOU
SUBSTANCE. USE TREATMENT DO
HAPPEN IN A ROLL CALL. SB FORTY
FOUR PORTANTINO COMING COLLEGE
TRANSFER NOTIFICATIONS DAY
PASSES AMENDED REQUIRED
COMPLIANCE BY PAUL TWENTY
TWENTY TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
SB FIVE TWENTY ONE PORTANTINO
SECTION A TAX CREDIT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB FIVE THIRTY TWO
PORTANTINO CITY OF GLENDALE
REDEVELOPMENT BONDS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. SB SIX HUNDRED
PORTANTINO. HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
DO YOU PASS. WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING IN. SB SIX TWENTY
TWO PORTANTINO CRIMINAL
OFFENDER RECORD INFORMATION
REFERRAL PERSONS ON SUPERVISED
RELEASE TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL. I'M SORRY SB SIX TWENTY
YOU IT GOES OUT ON A ROLL CALL
SB SIX NINETY FIVE PORTANTINO
SPECIAL EDUCATION DOCUMENT
TRANSLATION TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL AJ ARE SEVENTEEN BY
MISTER RAMOS MISSING A MURDER
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN AND GIRLS
ARE GETS OUT IN ANY ROLL CALL.
SB ONE THIRTY EIGHT ROTH TYPE
ONE DIABETES. NOTIFICATION
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB FIVE FIFTY
FOUR ROTH ADULT EDUCATION DAHLE
MOMENT TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE RUBIO
STATURE LIMITATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED EXTEND THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR PEER TO FIVE
YEARS WITHOUT ANY RESTRICTIONS.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
INFORMATION TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB SIX FIFTY RUBIO
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON DRUG
DONATION OF CANCER DRUGS HOLD
IN COMMITTEE. SB SIX SIXTY
EIGHT RUBIO URBAN WATER
SUPPLIERS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
RUBIO MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB FORTY TWO
SKINNER THE GETTING HOME SAFE
ACT YOU PASSES AMENDED REDUCE
COSTS BY ELIMINATION CERTAIN.
STATE AND COUNTY OBLIGATIONS
RELATED THE RELEASE OF INMATES.
THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB
FORTY FOUR SKINNER MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT
STRATEGY DO PASS ON OF THE ROLL
CALL. SB FORTY NINE SKINNER
APPLIANCE STANDARDS AND STATE
WATER PROJECT ASSESSMENT TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL. SB TWO
OH SIX SKINNER COLLEGE STUDENT
ATHLETE NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SPECIFY
CONFLICT OF INTEREST PROCEDURE
SECOND TOWN IN A ROLL CALL. SB
THREE THIRTY SKINNER HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT DO YOU PASSED ON A
ROLL CALL. SB THREE THIRTY
SEVEN SKINNER CHILD SUPPORT
PASSERIDAE PASSES A MANAGE
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OF PASSED
THROUGH INCREASED CLARIFY THE
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT COLLECTION
PROVISIONS THAT COULD HAPPEN IN
A ROLL CALL. SB FOUR SEVENTY
SKINNER CALPERS ONLINE FOOD
PURCHASES HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
FOUR SIXTY TWO STERN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FIRE MITIGATION
WORKFORCE CURRICULUM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB FOUR SIXTY THREE
STERN NATURAL GAS STORAGE WELLS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DIRECTION TO
DOG. IN IN REVIEW IT'S GAS
STORAGE REGULATIONS THAT GETS
OUT ON TO BE ROLL CALL. FOR
SEVENTY ONE STERN SUBPOENAS DAY
PASSES AMEND ELIMINATES UNITED
CATION REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR STERN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS WORK FORCE
TO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
FIVE FORTY TWO STERN
PRESUMPTION SUPPOSED DRAMATIC
STRESS TO PASS ON A. ROLL CALL
SB SIX THIRTEEN STERN STATE.
THANK YOU. YEAH. THAT'S STILL
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB SIX
THIRTEEN STERN STATE GHG
EMISSIONS RELATED TO FOOD
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB SIX TWENTY
SIX STERN MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX
HOLDING COMMITTEE SIX THIRTY
THIRDS SB SIX THIRTY THREE
STERN. SANTA SUSANA FIELD LAB
ON TRYING TO PASS AND IN A ROLL
CALL SB SEVEN THIRTY STERN
COMMISSION ON TECH EQUITY
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE STERN NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE BILL DAY
PASSES MEDICAL CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS REGARD THE TAHOE
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT THAT
GETS OUT IN ANY ROLL CALL. SB
FOUR SIXTEEN STONE REGIONAL
CENTER FAMILY FEES HOLDING
COMMITTEE SB SEVENTEEN I'M
BURKE CIVIL DISCOVERY SANCTIONS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
SECTION TWO OF THE BILL THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. SB
SEVENTY TWO AMBERG SAME DAY
VOTER REGISTRATION DO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL SB THREE NINETY
AMBERG SCHOOL SECURITY GUARD
TRAINING TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
AMBERG CLIMATE READY IN COASTAL
ADAPTATION TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL. SB SIX NINETY SIX
AMBERG NAMES OF POLITICAL
PARTIES TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REVISE THE DATES OF
IMPLEMENTATION THAT GETS OUT
AND BE ROLL CALL. SB. SEVEN
THIRTY SIX AMBERG CREATIVE
ECONOMY EVENT PROGRAM HOLDEN
COMMITTEE
. I'M GONNA GO BACK TO
SB SEVENTEEN BY AMBERG CIVIL
DISCOVERY SANCTIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH AS AMENDMENTS TO
COME. THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. SB THIRTEEN WHAT COUNTS
SKI SS THREE DWELLING UNITS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL DEFINE
IMPACT FEES CLARIFY THE AMNESTY
PROGRAM THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL SB ONE SIXTY WHAT CASKEY
CHEAP CLIMATE RESILIENCE
OFFICER HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB
WHAT FIVE EIGHTEEN WHAT KOWSKI
SELECTION SETTLEMENT OFFERS TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL. SB
TWENTY THREE WIENER UNLAWFUL
ENTRY OF A VEHICLE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SB THIRTY FOUR WINNER
TAX EXEMPTIONS FOR DONATED
CANNABIS DO PASS AS AMENDED
DISTRICT URGENCY CLOSET DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND TELL CDFA
DETERMINES THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY CHANGES
THAT HAPPEN MADE. SPECIFY
PROCESSES RETAILERS AND
CULTIVATORS MY FATHER PROVIDE
DONATED CANNABIS AT THEM FROM
TAXES. CLEAR FINE LICENSING
ENTITIES AUTHORITY TO SUSPEND A
LICENSE FOR VIOLATIONS PROHIBIT
CHANGING THE DESIGNATION ONCE
THE PRODUCT IS DESIGNATED FOR
DONATION OTHER CLARIFY MINOR
CONFORMING CHANGES THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL. A ROLL CALL. SB
FORTY WIENER HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP TO PASS AND IN
A ROLL CALL SB FIFTY EIGHT
WIENER FOR ATM BAR CLOSURE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CHANGE TO
THREE AM BAR CLOSURE THAT GETS
OUT ON OF THE ROLL CALL. SB
SIXTY NINE WIENER OCEAN
RESILIENCY ACT THAT BECOMES A
TO YOUR BILL SB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN WIENER COMPLETE STREETS
DO PASSED WITH OTHERS
AMENDMENTS TO DELETE
PROVISIONS. CREATING THE ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION ASSETS BRANCH
WITHIN CALTRANS REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT THE CALTRANS
PRESCRIBER PROCESS FOR COMPLETE
STREETS IMPLEMENTATION DELETE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT CALTRANS
INCORPORATE CERTAIN PERFORMANCE
TARGETS INTO ITS ASSET
MANAGEMENT PLAN. I CALTRANS
AUTHORITY TO UNDERTAKE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS PROJECTS FOR
CERTAIN FEATURES THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB ONE
THIRTY TWO WIENER CORRECTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO GRANT CCD
ARE MORE OVERSIGHT GRANT
INMATES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DECLINE ANY CHANGE IN PLACEMENT
OF IDENTIFICATION THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB ONE
THIRTY SIX WIENER SENTENCING DO
PASS AS AMENDED EXCLUDE ANY
PERSON WITH A PRIOR CONVICTION
FOR RAPE AGGRAVATED SEXUAL
ASSAULT OF A CHILD SODOMY ORAL
COPULATION. CHILD MOLESTATION
CONTINUOUS SEXUAL ABUSE OF A
CHILD. SEXUAL PENETRATION AN
ASSAULT AND KIDNAPPING WITH
INTENT TO COMMIT A SEX CRIME
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
SB ONE FORTY TWO WIENER
EMPLOYEE LACTATION.
ACCOMMODATION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE. THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP A GUIDANCE DOCUMENT
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. SB ONE FORTY FIVE WIENER
SEX REGISTRATION THAT BECOMES A
TO YOUR BILL. SB ONE FIFTY NINE
WIENER PREP AND PAP MEDICATION
FOR HIV PREVENTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SPECIFY FOR
EQUIVALENT DRUGS DEVICES ARE
PRODUCTS PREVENT HIV PLANS
INSURERS MUST COVER AT LEAST
ONE WITHOUT PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
OR STEP THERAPY THAT GETS OUT
IN A ROLL CALL. SB ONE SIXTY
SIX WIENER PROCESS WATER
TREATMENT CENTERS HOLD IN
COMMITTEE SB TWO SIXTY WIENER
LOCAL TAXES DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CLARIFY THE WORDS SEE VOTER
GUIDE FOR TAX RATE INFORMATION
ARE INCLUDED IN THE SEVENTY
FIVE BALLOT WORD REQUIREMENT
AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES. THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL SB
TWO EIGHTY FIVE WIENER CALPERS
PARTICIPATION HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB. FIFTY THREE WILK
ADVISORY BODIES HOLD IN
COMMITTEE. YEAH YEAH. YOU. YOU
WANT TO GO TO. SB ONE FIFTY
THREE WILK INDUSTRIAL HEMP TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB TWO OH
TWO WILK ANIMAL BLOOD DONORS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB TWO
NINETEEN WELL FOSTER YOUTH IN
RICHMOND GRAMS HOLD IN
COMMITTEE SB THREE THREE THREE
WELL HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WE ARE CONCLUDING
TODAY'S. ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE